bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
une nouvelle édition du Journal de la
rédaction il est 18h si vous nous suivez
en direct et dans l'actualité locale de
ce jeudi 19 février 2015 les mondiaux de
cyclisme qui se poursuivent au Vélodrome
national à 50 ans en Yvelines et
François Pervis représentant tricolore
installé à Montigny-le-Bretonneux et
défendait ses titres mondiaux à la
droite uni pour le scrutin des
départementales commence à exposer son
programme sur les différents secteurs
qu'elle entend faire basculer ainsi à
Trappes Jean-Michel fourgousse et Anne
Caprio évoque emploi et éducation le
comité yvelinois France Parkinson se
dote d'un nouveau président Jean-Yves
amatthieu et il est l'invité de cette
édition pour évoquer cette maladie dans
deux mois se tiendra la Journée mondiale
de la maladie de Parkinson
on va aller chercher le titre et donc
une médaille médaille d'or bien sûr je
pense qu'il serait déçu d'avoir une
médaille autre que le que le maillot ce
soir en plus ça lui permettrait
d'enlever la pression pour la suite
parce que son gros objectif c'est de
conserver un type de champion du monde
cette année ce qu'il a vraiment beaucoup
de compétition à sur ces championnats du
monde justement ça va pas être trop
difficile pour lui de gérer justement
les efforts c'était même programme
l'année dernière il a fait les trois
titres l'année dernière voilà il est
habitué il est préparé pour nickel
d'Almeida a le même programme et donc
ils sont préparés pour ça il y a aucun
souci j'ai posé la question hier à
Michael il y a un petit mot j'ai aussi
sur les autres Français qui sont engagés
aujourd'hui alors on a Sandie claire et
holly-les-montauban sur le 500 mètres
féminin elles n'ont jamais brillé au
niveau international maintenant on voit
très bien que le public
booste
public
on sent un très fort chauvinisme ça
marche avec des Français sont au lieu de
partout et ça crée beaucoup plus fort
avec des clés français c'est vrai que
donc les les va vraiment les booster et
donc bah pourquoi pas aller chercher un
podium un petit peu à comme à la failli
le faire hier ils disent Elise sur la
sur la course à points et justement un
petit mot sur sur Elise justement qui
est qui a terminé donc quatrième de la
course à points et deux fois avec une
chute avec une chute qui l'a plutôt
boostée qui l'a plutôt boosté en fait
pour pour la suite elle elle j'ai eu un
interviewel aujourd'hui et c'est vrai
que elle est tombée sur d'autres
épreuves ou elle a décroché des titres
donc du coup elle s'est dit je vais
gagner et le problème c'est qu'à 30
tours et ben elle va elle y a pas cru
assez elle aurait dû rester dans la
route allemande qui est qu'elle avait
pris un tour et c'est vraiment la petite
erreur qu'elle fait elle a tellement de
déconstration de petit tour et bah ça
lui coûte ça lui coûte la podium ça
pourra lui servir peut-être d'expérience
pour l'avenir j'en suis sûr c'est c'est
le type d'erreur qu'il faut ne pas
reproduire et un petit mot également sur
la belle médaille d'or justement des de
la vitesse par équipe française une
médaille d'or un petit peu sur tapis
vert mais mérité parce que bah ils ont
pas fait de fautes néo-zélandais on fait
une erreur une erreur pas de débutant
mais ils ont un point de règlement qui
n'a pas été respecté donc les Français
sont champions du monde ça lance très
bien la semaine pour pour l'équipe de
France ça va enlever la pression à tout
le monde justement ça pousse peut-être
l'équipe de France justement cette
première médaille ça lance complètement
ces championnats du monde ça modifie
complètement le si on avait fait
médaille d'argent la pression n'aurait
pas été la même parce qu'il faut aller
chercher ce premier titre pour pouvoir
démarrer correctement un championnat et
là bah c'est idéal pour pour la suite et
on a vraiment encore de très belles
chances aujourd'hui un petit mot sur
Grégory Baugé aussi l'autre tête
d'affiche donc du cyclisme tricolore ici
à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines vous avez
pensé quoi vous en pensez quoi de des
performances de Grégory Baugé sur ces ne
fais pas le meilleur temps sur sur le
premier tour mais voilà il est présent
je pense que son gros objectif est quand
même la vitesse Paris la vitesse
individuelle qui commencera samedi on
sait aussi que sur 200 m c'est pas lui
plus rapide mais c'est un vrai guerrier
et on a deux très belles chances de
médailles sur sur la vitesse de la
vitesse individuelle avec François
perdis et Grégory Baugé on regarde
justement le sujet sur justement dans un
instant mais peut-être pour vous faire
réagir vous qui êtes tous les deux là au
cœur de de cette piste de cette piste
record est-ce que on peut d'ores et déjà
dire après deux jours presque plein de
compétitions que c'est déjà un succès
cette organisation en France de ces
Mondiaux
pour l'instant oui on peut le dire les
places sont toutes vendues il y a 5500
spectateurs environ en moyenne là pour
l'instant nous sommes en pause donc là
pour l'instant les spectateurs vont à la
buvette etc mais sinon oui oui là on
peut dire clairement que que les
employés du monde sont pour l'instant
une réussite tout le monde a le sourire
et ça va durer et ça va durer surtout
que vous l'avez dit la France est d'ores
et déjà en or sur la vitesse par équipe
dominée par la Nouvelle-Zélande en
finale homme la France a finalement
obtenu ce titre lors d'une faute des
Néo-Zélandais la mauvais passage de
relais Grégory Baugé Kevin Siro et Kald
Almeida les Bleus décrochent leur
premier titre dans la discipline depuis
2009 dans cette discipline
c'est pas une fin en soi mais presque
donc voilà on va pas vous donner notre
plaisir aujourd'hui on est champion du
monde on est meilleurs on a on a ceci
boom maillot sur nos épaules donc voilà
on va on va en profiter à la sortie du
podium les Français ont salué la
performance de leurs adversaires du jour
on est très satisfait voilà on a quand
même franchi la ligne en 2e faut pas
l'oublier il y a une erreur technique de
nos adversaires est-ce que c'est ce qui
leur a permis de faire le meilleur temps
on sait pas on n'est pas là pour en
discuter ça fait donc un plusieurs
années qui sont aussi sur les podiums
mais ils étaient champions du monde en
titre l'année passée
une équipe forte aussi montante et je
pense que maintenant ça va être une
équipe qui va aussi côtoyer les les
places sur les jeux donc il va falloir
faire attention à eux et bien se
préparer une médaille et des espoirs
pour l'avenir l'esprits français sont
désormais considérés comme les favoris
pour un podium aux Jeux olympiques de
Rio en 2016 on pense à Rio depuis
bien longtemps depuis vous savez depuis
notre finale aux Jeux olympiques à
Londres on pense déjà à Rio on a vu ce
qui nous a manqué nous on est sans arrêt
dans la recherche pour rattraper ce qui
nous a manqué aujourd'hui on est
champion du monde c'est bien c'est beau
mais on va pas on va pas s'enflammer
c'est pas c'est pas une fin en soi il
faut pas on s'assoit pas là-dessus il y
a rien d'acquis les champion du monde
c'est pas le champion olympique c'est
pas la même chose avant de penser au jeu
de Rio et aux médailles olympiques les
sprinteurs tricolores veulent savourer
leur titre la France est une habituée de
cette distinction les Bleus ont
remportaient ce mercredi soir leur
onzième titre en vitesse par équipe
depuis 1995 un record
18h 8 si vous nous suivez en direct et
nous repartons tout de suite pour
Montigny-le-Bretonneux où se trouve ce
vélo Drôme national avec cette
compétition internationale qui se
déroule on va s'intéresser à présent aux
hommes de l'ombre un petit peu avec
Michael midoro qui est sur place pour la
rédaction vous êtes au côté d'un médecin
c'est ça je suis à côté du docteur
Francis Janson qui coordonne justement
tous les centres de secours ici oui le
don de national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alors ça se
déroule comment c'est c'est il y a
combien de personnes qui s'occupent
justement de l'infirmerie etc au
Vélodrome de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
alors on a trois infirmeries on a une
infirmerie de piste une infirmerie pour
le public et une infirmerie centrale
elles sont équipées avec tous les moyens
que vous pouvez imaginer ça va depuis le
cardioscope jusqu'à des
orthèses pour les fractures etc et elles
sont équipées de personnels bien sûr
nous sommes oui médecin
infirmière médecin du sport médecin
urgentiste infirmier ou infirmière
urgent et accompagner de 11 secouristes
avec deux ambulances et ça se passe
comment de quand à pouvoir se blesse sur
la piste comment ça se passe exactement
il est réceptionné par rapport à des
pompiers ça se passe comment expliquer
nous alors écoutez c'est tout simple de
chaque côté de la piste nous avons deux
secouristes de chaque côté de la piste
en attente de la chute avec ce qu'on
appelle brancard un plan dur s'il en
parle plus technique et de chaque côté
avec eux il y a également un médecin ou
une infirmière urgentiste donc dès que
la chute a lieu s'est déclenché par le
commissaire et moi-même qui envoie l'une
ou l'autre de ces deux équipes et selon
la gravité il est évident que d'autres
secouristes viennent aider les
secouristes qui sont sur la piste et la
fermier ou le médecin qui est sur la
piste parce qu'on peut avoir des chutes
avec 5 6 7 8 coureurs dans les dans
certaines en peloton et vous me le dites
tout à l'heure il y a également des
incidents dans le public aussi à dû à la
chaleur notamment qui est de 25 à 30
degrés sur la piste et même qui peut
monter jusqu'à 35 degrés dans les
tribunes alors effectivement on a
actuellement
ses paradoxal on n'a pas beaucoup de
chute mais on a énormément d'infectieux
parmi les coureurs et parmi le
affectueux c'est à dire en jean
bronchite etc mais parmi le public la
chaleur en haut j'ai monté donc un
thermomètre la chaleur en haut est à 37
degrés actuellement et nous avons des
enfants qui vomissent nous avons des des
personnes âgées qui font des malaises
vagal etc et vous êtes un petit peu une
légende dans dans le milieu médical sur
les championnats du monde et les Jeux
Olympiques vous êtes à 11 participations
c'est ça aux Jeux olympiques en tant que
médecin oui c'est exact je bon je suis
multicarte je devrais pas le dire
je devrais pas parler de moi je devrais
parler plutôt de mon équipe mais
effectivement je travaille dans quatre
fédérations sportives et je suis dans
quatre commissions médicales centrale
en particulier l'athlétisme etc mais
effectivement j'ai fait 11 jeux
olympiques comme un médecin avec
différentes spécialités et ces
championnats du monde ils sont réussis
selon vous là pour l'instant alors c'est
champion du monde sont exceptionnels
pour le spectacle mais pour nous au
niveau médical c'est aussi exceptionnel
parce que j'ai j'ai
une équipe qui est pleine de
convivialité et toute la journée nous
avons des moments dans les petites
pauses de convivialité style une tarte
aux pommes farcies style une tarte aux
quetsches parce que je suis Laurent et
donc voilà et rassurez nous le cyclisme
sur piste c'est pas dangereux le
cycliste le surpiste n'est pas dangereux
du tout ils sont extrêmement préparés la
préparation physique de ces sportifs
j'en ai eu beaucoup dans ma clientèle
puisque venant d'Aquitaine maintenant
j'avais un pôle France en Aquitaine dont
j'étais le responsable et où nous avons
eu tous ces champions du monde il y en a
quelques ingénieurs il y en a
quelques-uns qui sont maintenant seniors
et donc c'est des acrobates c'est des
acrobates et je dis et je le répète à
tous les entraîneurs je ne suis pas
entraîneur mais ça doit passer par la
piste obligatoirement il y a des
routiers qui ne veulent pas perdre de
piste mais c'est hyper important la
piste pour
l'acrobatie la souplesse etc sur route
vous avez noué des liens avec certains
couvreurs à force de les côtoyer bien
sûr j'ai
côtoyé un garçon que vous connaissez
bien et qui maintenant n'est plus dans
le staff équipe de France j'étais au
mariage de Florent Rousseau par exemple
j'ai eu dans ma clientèle
40 ans de clientèle 152 pro qui sont
devenus pro je les ai eu comme gamin je
les ai eu comme gamin ou gamine j'ai
rencontré là il y a pas dans mon hôtel
aujourd'hui ce matin par exemple
mademoiselle madame mais anciennement
mademoiselle Humbert qui qui tournait à
l'époque avec Catherine Marsal donc des
anciennes on a on
a toutes les gloires le docteur Janson
qui est intarissable on l'a bien entendu
merci pour ces témoignages et toutes ces
anecdotes merci on va finalement vous
laisser aller aider le public aussi
parce qu'on l'a bien compris là où c'est
le plus difficile dans ce chaudron qu'il
cesse de bouillir c'est tout en haut 37
degrés vous l'avez dit il y a du travail
donc pour vous et puis la compétition
qui va aussi reprendre merci
merci Mickaël n'hésitez pas à intervenir
à nouveau s'il y a du nouveau et des
évolutions des champions directeur
national qui qui se promènent dans le
coin n'hésitez pas à nous revenir vers
nous merci Michael et merci beaucoup on
va juste parler encore un petit peu de
ces événements de ces Mondiaux de
cyclistes mon écoutant à présent le
public événement qui se joue qui se
déroule à guichet fermé plus de 5000
personnes coûtait ce micro-trottoir
réalisé dans les traverses du vélo de
Rome j'ai vu le vélo de roman
construction je passe lui passer ici
pendant des années je l'ai vu grandir et
j'avais qu'un seul une seule attente
c'était de venir à la première grande
manifestation internationale et là
franchement c'est du bonheur on est venu
hier franchement tu es bien organisé
c'est très bien à la télé j'ai déjà vu
un petit peu mais bon là je crois que ça
va être quelque chose de de bien de
beaucoup mieux quand même ça va être
plus agréable on a pas beaucoup de
connaissances on a prié un petit peu sur
le terrain là les les consignes enfin
les informations et c'était du bonheur
et on va se régaler encore tous les
jours à suivre là et nous sommes ravis
et ne reviendrons certainement
c'est la première fois j'ai un vélo de
Rome et puis c'est le plus joli en
France qui vient d'être construit à 2013
c'est ça donc
l'impression la première impression
c'est magnifique allez pour François
et François Pervis qui est donc en
compétition les mondiaux de cyclisme qui
se poursuivent et c'est toujours à
suivre sur téléfils jusqu'à la fin de la
semaine et même lundi dans une édition
spéciale du 7 8 sport préparé par
Michael el mis Doro on reprend le cours
de l'actualité de ce jeudi 19 février on
va parler politique et ces élections
départementales dans le canton de
Trappes l'Union de la Droite vient de
tenir son premier point presse afin de
présenter son programme la droite qui va
tenter d'arracher ce secteur de traps
canton de trappes élancourt-la-verrière
à la gauche
ce qu'on travaille le maire d'Élancourt
en campagne aux côtés de sa deuxième
adjointe Jean-Michel fourgousse et Anne
capillo pour représenter la droite dans
ce scrutin départemental sur le canton
de Trappes qui couvre également les
villes de la verrière et d'Élancourt et
sans surprise le programme porte
principalement sur l'emploi mais aussi
sur l'éducation impliquée dans le
développement du numérique à l'école
dans leur ville le binôme souhaite
étendre le dispositif oui parce que
beaucoup de trappistes m'ont dit c'est
pas normal qu'on n'est pas le même
système qu'elle encourt pour nos enfants
donc message entendu oui on va leur
donner le même système qui est considéré
comme exemplaire en France de de
d'Élancourt plutôt qu'on voit les
Trappistes qui qui se battent pour venir
à Élancourt et si jamais facile ben on
va leur mettre le même système qu'elle
encourt là ainsi qu'à la verrière à ceux
qui se disent surpris par cette
candidature de Jean-Michel fourgouse que
l'on imaginait plutôt vouloir reprendre
en 2017 son poste de député perdu au
profit de Benoît Hamon le principal
intéressé évoque une nécessité pour
aider financièrement les villes du
secteur
aujourd'hui
il y a une asphyxie financière de toutes
les communes et dans cette situation la
solution c'est d'aller chercher des
fonds dans d'autres structures comme le
conseil général ou le conseiller
régional
en attendant que législatives et c'est
vrai que donc moi j'y vais pour aller
chercher de nouveaux moyens sur le
canton de trap 5 list se présente et la
gauche se montre particulièrement divisé
la liste menée par la divers gauche
sortante Janine marine n'a pas reçu le
soutien du Front de gauche et du Parti
communiste
et l'invité de ce 19 février c'est
Jean-Yves à Mathieu bonsoir et bienvenue
sur ce plateau vous êtes le nouveau
responsable local de France Parkinson on
va évoquer votre votre poste et puis
parler de cette maladie aussi on va
juste repartir quelques instants très
rapidement pour le pour le vélo drone
national Mickaël vous êtes avec le
directeur technique national c'est ça
Vincent Jacquet alors Vincent Jacquier
des championnats du monde ne pouvait pas
mieux commencer effectivement très belle
médaille d'or hier soir sortie vraiment
à la à la surprise avec cette
disqualification des Néo-Zélandais mais
je peux vous dire énormément de travail
des équipes de France effectivement on
est parfaitement content de cette
médaille ça nous a lancé ça lancé la
dynamique de l'équipe de France on l'a
vu aujourd'hui notamment sur la
poursuite par équipe puisque l'équipe de
France va de nouveau son record de
France se passe parmi les 8 meilleures
nations mondiales il faut savoir qu'il y
a 8 mois on était à la 29e place
aujourd'hui on a remonté petit à petit
effectivement c'est une belle
performance qu'on attend juste comment
vous expliquer juste comment vous
expliquer justement ce succès et cette
remontée aussi fulgurante de classement
le travail l'abnégation les valeurs le
respect et puis on a mis tout un socle
de relation avec le secteur
professionnel puisque la quasi-totalité
même la totalité des membres de l'équipe
de France de poursuite par équipe et
dans une équipe professionnelle donc on
a relié on a retissé du lien avec les
directeurs des équipes Pro et on a
planifié la saison et ensuite
parfaitement bien le révolution c'est un
travail partagé et ce renouveau il est
là aussi et
l'objectif oui toujours 5 médailles on
les espère on a une chance de médaille
par soi donc effectivement on attend
impatiemment le kering ce soir avec deux
représentants dans les demi-finales
François Pérusse et Michael d'Almeida
sur les féminines le 500 mètres avec une
rentrée en liste de sang d'Hitler et on
vous souhaite bien évidemment encore
plein de succès on y reviendra bien sûr
sur TV film merci Vincent Jacquet merci
Michael également donc on passe à
présent à l'entretien de cette édition
du journal je le disais avec Jean-yves à
Mathieu pour parler de cette association
France Parkinson on va parler de la
maladie tout d'abord une maladie
neurodégénérative chronique elle se
caractérise comment cette maladie de
Parkinson
caractérise par un problème de motricité
c'est à dire que les patients qui sont
atteints de cette maladie vont avoir des
des raideurs des
douleurs et ainsi de suite donc de façon
assez importante et c'est ce qui est
caractérise la maladie même si il y a
peut y avoir des temps en temps des
tremblements et c'est ce que les
l'opinion publique détecte en premier
c'est les tremblements alors que les
tous les médecins voient les normalement
les signes cliniques du à l'arrêter vous
dites l'opinion publique justement ce
qui est souvent retenu par le grand
public c'est c'est l'âge avancé pour
être victime de cette maladie et
pourtant la moyenne d'âge c'est 58 ans
tout à fait il y a des gens qui qui ont
la maladie de Parkinson à 40 ans et qui
vont vivre pendant 30 ou 40 ans avec
cette maladie là on peut l'accompagner
on peut vivre avec quels sont les
traitements aujourd'hui ça ne se soigne
pas non ça ne soigne pas les traitements
bon les traitements vont compenser le
manque de dopamine mais ce qui est
important c'est justement de de
commencer à travailler pour ne pas avoir
des problèmes de raideur c'est à dire
qu'il faut faire de l'exercice physique
comme prescrit à l'ensemble des
personnes qui prennent un peu d'âge
c'est à dire que c'est bien de faire de
des exercices c'est bien d'aller à la
piscine c'est bien d'aller d'avoir un
kiné c'est bien de se bouger la
recherche avance malgré tout elle avance
et France Parkinson la sponsorise par
ses budgets et autres et donc apporte
une somme aux alentours de 800000 € tous
les ans pour la recherche en particulier
ça fait partie de vos missions vos
missions également parmi vos missions
également accompagner l'entourage parce
que c'est très difficile pour
l'entourage forcément on parle des
malades mais l'entourage il faut aussi
on appelle les gens des aidants dans
notre jargon c'est à dire c'est le
conjoint souvent de la personne qui va
accompagner et qui va faire que de
continuer à se bouger et autres qui va
motiver au début c'est à dire qu'il qui
sait moi je sais que par exemple ma
femme me motive de bouger et de faire
des choses par contre un peu plus tard
il y a des gens c'est aussi qui ils vont
arrêter de conduire donc ils vont être
besoin d'être de garder la mobilité à
travers leur conjoint vous êtes atteint
de cette maladie vous l'avez appris
comment vous l'avez vécu et comment vous
le vivez aujourd'hui
moi je l'ai vécu disons
normalement pour moi parce que dans ma
famille il y avait mes parents l'avaient
et c'est bon il faut voir que
la maladie de Parkinson dans 15% des cas
c'est héréditaire et donc à partir du
moment où on a dans son entourage des
gens qui ont eu la maladie de Parkinson
et qui ont vécu et qui vivent encore
avec c'est disons acceptable par contre
il y a des gens qui ont des vues des
personnes atteintes de la maladie du
Parkinson qui était très diminué et là
ça peut faire un choc c'est une maladie
qui est méconnue finalement parce qu'on
m'en parle on parle souvent librement
enfin c'est vous parlez de cette
tremblements il y a beaucoup d'idées
reçues
qui ont la maladie de Parkinson en
France
donc c'est beaucoup quand même bon c'est
vrai que pour Alzheimer c'est 800000
mais justement quand j'évoquais cet
aspect là méconnu est-ce que les
pouvoirs publics sont saisis c'est ce
qu'il y a des plans d'actions qui sont
menés est-ce que c'est suffisant de
votre point de vue en tant qu'associatif
et responsable sur sur le département de
tout à fait donc un livre blanc qui a
été établi par transparkinson qui a été
communiqué au gouvernement il y a un
plan maladie neurose dégénérative qui a
été mis en place alors au départ il
devait pas y avoir trop de choses de
Parkinson par contre tout a été mis
dedans donc on se pose des questions
parce que quand on met tout ça veut dire
que c'est peut-être un petit peu
difficile mais il faut scinder les deux
parce que Parkinson et Alzheimer c'est
vrai que c'est une maladie au niveau du
cerveau mais les conséquences sont pas
du tout les mêmes il y a des adhérents
il y a des bénévoles aussi dans votre
association quel est le rôle d'un
bénévole les bénévoles c'est des fois de
d'être simplement une personne qui peut
prendre un coup de fil qui peut aider
quelqu'un à nouveau mais il y a aussi
des bénévoles comme des psy il y a aussi
des bénévoles comme des gens de qui vont
permettre d'aider des par exemple des
des personnes qui travaillent et donc il
faut les aider lors de connaître leurs
droits et autres donc des juristes qui
vont aider on voit quelques images
c'était cet après-midi la nouvelle
directrice générale qui est venue
rencontrer justement les malades les
adhérents les bénévoles ça fait partie
aussi de vos missions vous organisez
beaucoup de rencontres il y en a eu
encore aujourd'hui discussion entre
malade pour tout favoriser l'échange il
faut que parce que c'est vrai qu'il y a
quand même bon dans ces maladies un
petit peu difficiles peut y avoir
beaucoup de déni on va dire des gens qui
veulent pas en parler qui veulent pas le
dire qui veulent pas échanger qui qui
restent dans leur coin qui qui ne
sortent plus donc il faut et justement
France Parkinson est là pour les aider
pour mettre en place aussi des des
activités comme de la chorale comme de
l'aide et danse et autres pour que
justement les gens se motivent un peu de
faire des choses vous êtes le nouveau
responsable départemental vos priorités
les priorités moi c'est surtout de
d'accès mon travail par rapport aux
jeunes diagnostiqués de façon à pouvoir
les aider à pouvoir trouver des
solutions et de faire des choses avec
eux pas toujours avec des groupes de
parkinsoniens comme on dit mais aussi
avec des gens parce qu'il faut rester
dans le monde normal il faut pas aller
tout de suite du côté des malades parce
que sinon après bon sachant qu'on a 20
ou 30 ans à vivre avec on a le temps d'y
arriver et puis c'est surtout de comment
dire de les aider de
faire en sorte que l'opinion publique
que les gens se posent des questions
quand ils commencent à avoir des
raideurs si on a 60 ans et qu'on a des
raideurs c'est pas toujours des
rhumatismes un signe tout à fait
il y a des choses aussi comme par
exemple Parkinson il y a la perte de
l'odorat et beaucoup de gens qui ont
perdu l'odorat 5 ou 6 ans avant d'être
diagnostic et vous par exemple pendant
votre cas il y a eu des signes
annonciateurs
avaient la maladie de Parkinson et ma
fille orthophoniste elle m'a dit à plus
récent de plus en plus à Papy c'est à
dire que quand tu te promènes tu
balances pas trop les bras tu es un peu
voûté tu es un peu raide tu traînes les
pieds bon et donc elle m'a dit consulte
et puis elle m'indiquer un professeur à
consulter à la Pitié-Salpêtrière donc
n'hésitez pas à consulter si vous avez
des inquiétudes en tout cas aussi vous
rapprocher des associations comme France
Parkinson et qui pourra vous renseigner
merci Jean j'arrive à Mathieu d'être
passé sur ce plateau nouveau responsable
donc du comité Vinois de France
Parkinson c'est la fin de ce journal
votre soirée sur TV Phil c'est notamment
avec Floran parfait pour philico à
demain vendredi pour le journal de la
semaine et puis bien sûr sur un point
complet sur ces mondiaux de cyclisme qui
se déroulent actuellement au Vélodrome
national à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
bonne soirée